to me patriotism is one of the most
powerful and one of the most important
emotions there isn't it's it's what has
helped guide my life and why I worked in
the work I do and why I worked in public
service and why I've tried to help the
country you know live up to its ideals
in the work I do now as a lawyer the
patriotism doesn't mean being jingoistic
it doesn't mean putting other people
down
it means believing in your own country
which means believing in the people of
your own country and in the case of the
United States it means believing in the
ideals of the country you know it's been
said a lot that the United States is
very unusual that we were founded not
based on land and not even based on
religion or law or or ethnicity the way
a lot of other countries were but a
basic set of ideals and if you adhere to
those ideals if you believe in the
Declaration of Independence if you
believe in the Constitution then you're
an American that is a very powerful idea
it's the most basic and universal idea
there is and if you get excited about
that you're patriotic whether you wear a
flag